Biden's ATF submitted a new rule last
year targeting unregistered ghost guns
before we get into the content of that
rule let's just take a look at what
Biden had to say about the threat of
ghost guns as justification for the
atf's actions
this is the gun
it's not hard
to put together
a felon a terrorist a domestic abuser
can go from a gun kit
to a gun as little as 30 minutes in fact
the ATF reports that they've been able
to trace less than one percent less than
one percent
of ghost guns reported by law
enforcement and we're acting today the
United States Department of Justice is
making it illegal for a business to
manufacture one of these kits without a
serial number illegal
illegals what's your reaction Cody
I'm immediately reminded of Dr Steve
Brule played by John C Reilly and his
famous Sushi skit um check it out he
says uh
it's not hard to let other people from
different countries talk to you he said
he sounds exactly like Dr Steve brol so
maybe that's a deep cut but uh I feel
bad for the president you know and that
was a great moment for polymer 80
because of course Joe Biden's rule was
workshop for him by every town in
Giffords to Target what had become a
very popular type of at-home kit DIY kit
for making concealable unregistered
handguns the polymer 80 kit that was
it's it's great moment so yeah it's it's
fun to see it again
yeah and uh so we're everyone's kind of
on the same page about what we're
talking about here
um these are examples of 80 lowers and
Frames um and so basically the
government uh wanted to the atf-12
classify these as something that had to
be registered I talked with you uh last
January uh shortly after this uh this
rule was first published by the ATF and
I'm just going to play a quick clip from
that that conversation because it
quickly explains kind of the mechanics
here and then we can discuss you know
how things have progressed since then
if the rules adopted in the coming weeks
it means the federal government will
require gun part kits sold on the
Internet by defense distributed and its
competitors to Bear the same serial
numbers as do fully manufactured
Firearms which has the potential to put
the entire industry out of business so
how is Wilson responding
meet the zero percent receiver anything
on its way to being a gun is now
considered a gun so say I Uncle Joe
and this would be smart you would think
if you're a wine mom or a lawyer who Now
controls the ATF you know this is Gabby
Gifford's Grand achievement to end kit
guns in the mail but that's just it this
was only a reaction to Kit guns in the
mail our equipment our software 3D
printing and CNC milling can take raw
materials
blocks of metal things in their
primordial State and take them from
nothing and turn them into guns Wilson
and his team tweaked the code to the
latest model of the ghost Gunner it used
to be the customers would purchase
partially fabricated lower receivers
using the ghost Gunner to finish the job
of turning them into functional gun
parts Wilson said that defense
distributed is the only DIY Gun Company
pivoting in the face of this new
regulation so the real impact of the law
will be to drive out his competitors
with this rule that Biden's pursuing
he's giving us the the nation's Premier
Ghost Gun Company I would say a monopoly
of the market
so how how has it played out since then
you know in terms of adoption because
when we're talking about going from
something that's partially finished to
something that's a raw material I
imagine that's a little bit more work
have people been ordering these and and
making things out of the zero percent uh
receiver blocks or non-receiver blocks
thank you uh yeah since since our piece
and your piece thankfully was a big part
of adoption our centerpiece yes we did
about a solid Year's worth of business
with the with the ar0 and it was it was
cool we took it to Shot Show uh unssf
SHOT show lots to say about that
organization right now but people got it
yeah people bought a lot of it and they
got it but what's so interesting is like
at the time that I spoke to you we were
predicting a more effective rule that
would actually ban entirely most 80
receivers or receiver kits and certainly
the language at that time time suggested
as much and by the time the final rule
was published we were all surprised that
most 80 receivers survived and so you
ended up getting these pieces like in
the New York Times and
um all these gun controllers came out
with buyers remorse saying well actually
the rule wasn't what we thought it was
and and so the to some degree in that in
that next year after that piece AR zeros
or zero percent receivers didn't become
necessary uh because the Monopoly wasn't
required the the industry survived and
in fact began to abuse the rule in
different directions so it's awesome and
hilarious that we didn't have to go that
way so the new conversation the new zero
we have today I'll I can show you it has
a retrospective point of view instead of
this predictive one that that we had
with you at that time that's one way to
answer your question could you just
explain what it is that you are
launching and how that fits into kind of
the the progression of Defense
distributed yeah you you showed a video
of Joe Biden holding up a polymer 80 kit
and the pulmonary kit is a Glock type
gun that you could basically order in
the mail
nearly finished you finish it yourself
with hand tools and about you know Bing
you gotta you gotta Glock so
um his rule was about stopping
commercial kit guns in the mail and uh
if he could trying to go after 3D
printed Glocks which some other states
have done but I was like I was thinking
well okay now the rule is kind of
failing let's do another version of a
way to do a block at home okay so you
can print the frame everyone's done that
but what if this is no longer a frame
sorry I'm not good at holding this up
what if this is no longer the regulated
part what if this is the regulated part
this is a chassis
you know people in the gun world are
familiar with like the Sig P320 and
cassette style triggers and anyway the
ATF is forced to observe that the metal
component that holds the Fire Control
Parts is the firearm and then in
combination then
um this what would have been a frame and
a Glock is no longer regulated so it's
like a it's like a doubling down against
the ATF rule they can't regulate blocks
of metal anyway they said they couldn't
you know a low carbon steel by the way
and um you know this is I think this is
one of our 4140 frames yeah so we've
been testing 17-4 41 40 303 stainless
you know what's machinable what's
affordable the point is this is this is
as good uh as a polymer 80 kit or a
block itself if anything we've taken
Trends in 3D printing and kit blocks
combine them recombine them remix the
Glock itself in Stark Defiance of the
terms of Biden's ghost gun Rule and said
hey good job on that rule it was already
you know it was already falling it's
push a judge will disable it and yet
here's another way of doing it it's it's
ultimately you know addressed to the ATM
hey thanks for watching and excerpt from
our conversation with Cody Wilson you
can watch the full conversation right
here or another clip from that
conversation right here and tune in next
Thursday at 1 pm Eastern for another
reason live stream